[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
welcome back to the break room our daily
show that keeps you updated on just
what's going on in nerd news from our
very own break room
that's right we're broadcasting live
from our super secret headquarters here
at new rockstars uh and we're so excited
to be here live with you today we got
lots of stuff to talk about on the show
uh we got some headlines about ezra
miller more like ezra still here jessica
wrote that joke and wanted me to read it
i need you to read a word for words do
not okay i'll do i'll do it on this one
you scream we scream we all scream for
mahershala ali
[Music]
all right uh we also have mcu's hottest
not-so-new couple and why wanda didn't
just look for vision
who cares about the kids where's your
man
make more of them uh and uh
and here at the break room we're gonna
pick apart each other's illuminati like
so many pieces of string cheese uh i'm
of course brandon i'm here with all of
my fellow hosts today my good friends we
got jessica clements here next to me
how the hell he held it uh we also have
tommy bechtold full of show energy today
hydrating and vibrating my friends i
want to thank everybody for joining that
charlie horse discourse yet
we're good we're fueled we're doing
rules we're doing that and of course uh
we have zach huddleston on the show
today i've been stretching hammy since
88 baby
oh my god uh we got a pack show today uh
and we'll be talking about doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness of
course spoilers everywhere if you
haven't seen the movie yet what are you
doing on this channel go see the movie
please uh we'll be talking about that
and of course we're taking your super
chance today
and all super chats will go into the
swear jar people have been clamoring for
this swear jar they love it they can't
get enough of it we're so clean here at
new rock stars we don't like to say the
bad words but if you pay us the money
we'll drop a bad word or two every time
our super chats add up to a hundred
bucks one of us gets the curse whoever
gets to see it first tommy watches that
board like a madman i'm watching it
we're one tenth of the way there someone
dropped 90 in the chat so i can go off
he really really really wants to use a
curse where we you know we keep it real
clean around the office this is uh not
only a place where we make content for
youtube but it's also a daycare we got
little kids running around all over the
place we can't curse in front of them
but if you pay the big bucks we'll curse
for you that's right
that's what we like to do that's right
yes and if you pay the really big bucks
i'll put a curse on your enemy oh
[Music]
next style yeah tommy has powerful chaos
magic that he likes to spread across the
multiverse
that's good hand work they called him
dark hold bechtold back
back in the day yeah
okay but as as we will uh every episode
of the break room we're going to start
with headlines
[Applause]
we're gonna cover all all the things
burglaring up in the surface of news
that that you want to stay in touch with
uh as brandon mentioned right there was
this rumor kind of circulating that ezra
miller might be
replaced
of course he's had some uh personal and
legal don't go to hawaii right now guys
it's not safe ezra miller is
one of the pigs he's one of the boards
that's running around and you know what
we feel bad uh for the guy for anybody
interacting with the guy right now but
warner brothers uh as reported via
variety is not currently looking to
replace him that movie's not coming out
until next year so they're probably
hoping he gets his s together in the
meantime yeah and things chill out we
want him in a good place ezra we want
you in a good place i also might have uh
mislabeled him with a male pronoun my
apologies mr god damn i don't know
my apologies ezra they deserve to be
referred to by their preferred pronouns
the mad goose wizard as far as i know
i say that every time uh other news
scarlet scarab aka layla from moon
knight aka mei kalamawi is the name of
the actress i love kala maui
get out of here delicious uh fried
dipped in uh
i don't mind if it's just from raw okay
um she did an interview recently where
she talked about how she would love to
appear in blade specifically of all the
upcoming marvel content uh because she's
previously worked with mahershala ali
the blade actor uh and she would love to
work with them again they work together
in the series rami
um she would also love uh to appear in
agatha i also because she likes villains
i also love this when
an actor is like yeah i'd appear in
multiple mca
honestly
if they i mean like it would be cool
with me
yeah i'm pretty busy tommy you'd appear
in uh agatha right if you twisted my arm
part of it yeah yeah yeah um oh we got a
we got a graphic here uh chris hemworth
chris hemsworth shared an instagram pic
uh of his with his co-star natalie
portman there yes some couple goals
going on there uh it says uh the captain
says hey all when's the met gala
asgard's power couple just found that
winning look don't go to the met gala i
do love this
chris hemsworth what are you doing uh
speaking of ezra miller they've had some
great looks at the med gala over the
years um but i i do love both of those
costumes it looks cool very old school
very thor one yeah yeah with the gold
kind of built into his costume uh and
the classic like circles yeah that was
like an ultimate thing right like he
always had the circles
yeah those are great looks um and then
uh brandon you keep bringing this up in
the office i keep bringing it up that
you were pounding the pavement for a tom
cruise multiverse and madness cameo yeah
i thought you know i thought it could be
we could get it you know he was supposed
to be iron man way many many years ago
before robert downey got bailed out of
prison uh it was gonna be old tommy cruz
but thank god he did the jack reacher
movies instead i've always wanted us
those are my shows for you yeah that
that is a multiverse i personally do not
want to visit but um then it had been
long rumored there was fan art out there
of tom cruise as iron man but uh
multiverse madness writer marco michael
waldron squashed those rumors and said
that that was always just a fake out
right there was zero plans to have tom
cruise show up as iron man there was no
cut footage nothing like that um
so just a twinkle in in a fan yeah they
were saying in the article the guy
really pushed it was like did anyone
like reach out to tom and they're like
no he's not available because he's doing
22 mission impossible movies
back-to-back oh yeah
like i think someone it was probably
agents like shutting it down
if tom got the call he might have showed
up i also just like that michael
waldron's like i'm a huge fan of tom
cruise so of course i was gonna try
putting him in one of my favorites it's
a little bit like uh the layla actress
being like i'd appear in other marvel
properties of course you're a fan of tom
cruise right
um of course you would love for him to
have a cameo in your film um oh uh
speaking of multiverse madness elizabeth
olsen
did an interview recently where she said
she will not be appearing in agatha
house of harkness the upcoming act of
the focus disney plus series um she said
of course she loves working with
catherine hahn no plans of course yeah
she's a great actress we all loved her
portrayal of agatha but no plans to
appear in that series now that is a
little bit of a disappointment it is but
i wonder if it's uh
obligatory doctor strange has only been
out for five days uh and every piece of
press she's gonna do for the next two
months she's gonna be like as far as i
know i'm not gonna appear in anything
you know she did say the thing where she
would love to keep appearing in these
movies but i'm sure confirming that
she's gonna appear in something would
probably set off the old fiji she did
say in that interview she was like uh
yeah feige like she was like and she
like literally called him out and was
like if you want to put me in it i'm
always down i love catherine han and i'm
like that's that's how you do it you
really call them out call them out in
the interview elizabeth if you are going
to be in this show never tell us
don't ever tell us you're going to be in
it no magazines tell us no internet
sites tell us you're surprised
she's no tom holland uh spoiling stuff
ahead of time no leaks coming out of uh
house olson over there uh speaking of
elizabeth olsen
in the same interview or a similar
interview
she was asked why she wasn't searching
for vision instead of her boys yes right
uh both in this right if she has the
ability to cross multiverses in search
of her sons why not cross multiverses
looking for vision
and um here's her answer uh we liked
having the mystery you know maybe they
got divorced maybe they're separated i
guess this would be an alternate
dimension
in the 8 3 8 that she ends up in yeah
right kind of the the wanda that she
possesses we never see vision there
right we do see ultron centuries so we
can assume maybe vision exists in this
world right we never see him uh and so
that is fun to think that like he does
exist in that world but they're divorced
well and even the existence of ultron
centuries right means maybe the ultron
program went right and there was never a
vision made and they never figured that
out i was also going to say even if
they're okay so that's the one the world
that we're in right now or the universe
that we see if there's a different
reality where there is a vision i also
like the idea of like why would you want
to go to the universe where like west
view he talked you out of doing
everything that you were doing so it's
like if she's already corrupted why
would you go to the man that's like you
know this is wrong and it's like you're
you're get out of my way i'm gonna get
my kids it's probably easier to take the
kids easy way easier to take the kids
have less life experience like they you
know they haven't gone through things
like she needs a vision that's gone
through what she's been doing right now
she doesn't need like a vision who's had
like a happy life
of course
the kids will be definitely traumatized
with a dopaminer of their mom
steals them in the movie every time
someone was like your children are gonna
know what you did and she's like i don't
care
they'll be happy because they're with me
but they won't have chicken pox
yeah we'll just keep going to universe
and i'll keep killing the other
wanderers i was like damn this is fast
she's gonna keep killing the other
billion tommy's too like were they just
gonna replace the whole family nuclear
family in every new uh universe like
she's about that she's gonna end up with
like a thousand kids she's gonna put it
all look the same she just wants to
probably go to the drugstore and get the
medicine and then get out yeah she just
wants to go to the cbs go to the cvs get
the character i thought they were just
moving to those well um
if he's acting up you know he's a
teenager he's like i hate you mom he's
like i'll get another billy yeah you're
affordable
you're replacing if she that's the way
she gets them you're replaceable
speaking of that
uh multiverse yeah for our break room
breakdown today we're gonna talk a
little bit about what we can infer from
that 838
and eric went into this a little bit in
his own breakdown let's take a look at
the clip from his breakdown of
multiverse of madness the world building
of 838 is really cool all the citizens
wear monochromatic colors which might
just be a hint of the cold functionality
of the society the emphasis being on
natural beauty over the artificial kind
of beauty of fashion and just visually
for the sequence it helps strange in
america stick out like sore thumbs here
also a little detail i thought was
interesting if you look around pretty
much everyone is carrying an umbrella
that might be connected to those rainbow
colored clouds overhead which might be
an indicator that in this universe rain
and weather patterns are actually
artificially controlled scheduled on
clockwork coordinated by reed richards
maybe by aurora monroe storm as well a
measure that they take to help combat
climate change ensure plant life is
properly hydrated and the people who
live here just kind of have to deal with
rain being part of their lives all the
time
eric's breakdown of multiverse of
madness if you haven't watched it yet
set aside 45 minutes of your life and do
that um besides 90 and watch it twice
hit the like button on there uh but yeah
this 838 right it looks like a beautiful
paradise i mean the all the plants it
looks so nice and there's there's pizza
papa it looks like a great place
for that alone yeah does that look too
nice like is there some something that
various going on like that eric pointing
out the monochrome colors of everybody
was really interesting also they are
unsmiling unspeaking right like there's
no laughter in this world
which some of that could be their
background actors that are just being
told to hit their marks yeah yeah yeah
but it does feel like the costuming was
purposeful this is not like normal
utopian star trek
where like sure people have kind of
standardized outfits but you get to see
some fun colors and some different mixes
and matches right i agree with this
universe um in probably the worst way
possible because i have such a cluttered
life and a cluttered lifestyle that i'm
just like i like this like this
yeah
then you would agree with north korea
yeah very orderly
you heard it here first folks
jessica confirmed communist jessica
clements um well i i like this we've
been talking in the office about the
little hints that maybe this is not like
a more
better universe than we are and a lot of
that hinges on how strange is treated
yeah as well yeah it made him into this
almost like deity he's the only one who
sacrificed himself to kill thanos and
we've we've seen that uh even a
multiverse of madness right when doctor
strange runs into his former doctor
friend whose name i forget at the
funeral and he's like michael schulberg
yeah yeah he's like did it have to go
the way it went and we've seen
throughout a lot of the series on disney
plus that
the citizens know a lot about the events
of the battle that took place with
thanos you know it seems like michael
struhlberg knows that uh you know dr
strange made this decision for things to
play out this way
in 838 they don't know what happened
they have no idea this illuminati is
like lying to them we have to imagine
that like the baxter foundation has a
lot of control over the city if eric's
right that like they control like the
weather and stuff like that yeah you
know it must trickle down to everything
but this society still has food you have
to pay for it still has yeah and it has
it has food carts i will say to me it
felt very
like elvis huxley to me technology is
way out yeah everything's a little too
clean there seems to be a void or a
missing emotional stakes to anything
people seem very robotic or compliant
also also perhaps afraid to be there are
places where without your consent will
suck out your most traumatic memory and
play it right in front of you in public
is that a weird manipulation
i wonder if they ordered that off the
menu they're like trauma memory please
whereas i would be like first kiss all
right i feel like 36 i feel like we're
hating on this a little too much but
also i'm too nervous to make any point
because i don't want to be impressed i
don't want to be immediately groping
voting
i also was like this is a universe that
we obviously have to recognize uh not
only did they defeat thanos but also
if they were living this life for longer
than we imagined it was generations upon
generations living this life why are
they going to see the customs as weird
like they're probably like in our
universe like you guys are scattered and
that's probably why you have so many
problems like they're like and they're
going to color options
why are you guys all so different i like
your first point not only did they
defeat thanos they defeated thanos
without a snap yeah
they defeated famous at the end of
infinity war basically
it's like they're like oh we don't
really know we just know that this guy
died to save all of us you could make it
the argument it was a much more
efficient defeat of thanos also they had
fewer heroes it was just the illuminati
members well it was cleaner
yeah it was cleaner
it's a little more ruthless mm-hmm
all signs of a dystopia
if you thought it was so crazy i'm not
trying to use this as my main example
but if it was so wild they have people
like bruce bam or bruce banner sorry
bruce campbell that is like selling the
pizza and being so crazy in a wackadoo
that i'm kind of like okay it's not so
normal it's not so chaotic i don't know
maybe maybe that bruce campbell was just
though it's like a cloned or like maybe
they make pizza poppas they manufacture
pizza pops you could have been an
android i don't know it's about it
anymore they're so weird he was such a
standout character that's like a show
crazy it's a
people keep walking by when he starts
attacking himself no one's helping him
why would i keep your head down
everyone feels very disconnected from
each other almost as if they're running
on a program like almost a matrix like
everyone's going through their sequences
walking to their jobs walking to their
homes whatever and then there's pizza
papa a fun little program that they made
you know
just to kind of mix it up a little bit
then you got your memory stores and you
got your two bookstores
two bookstores in the whole town
the whole cloud book that's two more
than most cities have now maybe they
have too many their superheroes are just
like too much because i feel like we
have a lot of superheroes but if they
already have the fantastic four and then
they also have the x-men they're
probably over-seen
they have inhumans in humans as well
presumably i i think the illuminati is a
death squad and every time they find
powered individuals black bolt goes and
erases them yeah i don't see any other
x-men we don't see any other avengers
well i do like this idea right like kind
of to me the darkest element they might
hint at eight two eight eight three
eight i keep wanting to say eight two
eight eight three eight not being a
great place is the fact that they lied
to the populace it's a very watchmen
kind of mentality right we've got to
provide everybody for the greater good
greater especially as we've seen in the
616 universe anytime that happens
whether it's being done by shield you
know
hydra whatever big organizations that
hide things from the general population
it almost never turns out to be a good
thing yeah you know this is very much a
our version of what people think the
illuminati is doing right controlling
the world behind the scenes and lying to
all of us that's fake but in this uh
film universe and that's so fair i was
also really intrigued by
the the all the signs right on the
street were like just pictures like a
lot of pictographs and even the road
sign was like a series of dots yeah it
wasn't lettering now they still have the
written language right because we saw it
on the statue uh for darkness was it
like dot dot was it like braille it was
it almost looked like uh if you had a
grid of dots and certain ones were
missing to indicate but why would you
need to why would people need to be less
educated so they could be more easily
controlled
look for the symbols people 838 liberate
yourselves do your own research
abide by this world because of the pizza
papa keep going well i mean i would live
in pizza papaya i got a question i got a
question i got a question i got a
question
who is in the empty chair why is there
an empty chair who is in the empty chair
yeah because we also didn't see a
seventh person at the flashback to titan
right no seventh person shows up to help
defend wanda and a lot of very uh
enthusiastic fans of the break room we
call them break heads we call them
breakdancers
we call them breakers roomies yeah we
call them roomies yes i thought you said
groomies i said we don't want to touch
that one uh they have been uh tweeting
at me
instead of direct messaging me finding
me on linkedin some people showed up at
my house the other day uh and they're
saying oh no it's dr strange's chair not
so not so because we know mordos said he
took dr strange's place and we don't see
him in the flashback on top right so
someone
belongs in that chair
no one can hear you oh uh this is uh
molina off screen asking is the same
person in the seventh chair who they
have a statue for are you referring to
the doctor strange statue no the statue
that kills captain marvel oh yeah it was
it looked like uh it almost looked
wonder womany didn't it it looked like
maybe an old like greek i was wondering
if it was supposed to be like athena
yeah
like an eternal statue
that's who's not represented in the deus
right like the illuminati could have
wiped out the eternals like we got to
get rid of these these are like the
narcs or the celestials we got to kill
them i feel like it it has to be someone
important but
like
if it's someone that big it's like this
was a huge thing that dr strange from a
different reality came here i think it
was on may
okay so sure
sorry
to say that brilliant
worth it
i think it was brandon playing uncle ben
uh not the rice not to be confused with
the black man on the rice oh i love when
you do that impression
[Laughter]
but yeah
i've seen the movie twice i was like who
is the statue you're supposed to be and
it's not super clear no but it seems
like could it be a statue that
represents each of the members that are
already the six
because could it be captain marvel it's
kind of like it's clearly very old right
because it's like missing some pieces
like it's it's either thousands of years
old or it was in a battle or something
like that i do like the idea that maybe
it's representing an eternal and maybe
they're just off world in this
multiverse but it's like you shouldn't
be off world for this moment it's like
come down right now and then they all
died
right now uh chrissy a very helpful uh
companion and fan of the show has a
great suggestion uh it was ant-man we
just couldn't see him
he ran in because he knew he couldn't
fight one i mean i do wonder if he was
gonna want his butt like the thanos
theory i wonder if it was somehow
related like the empty chairs related to
wakanda in any way right i wanted to be
now because that's what i wanted to be a
missing kingdom that's not represented
by the uh uh the deus of the illuminati
or under the sea no name or either yeah
i mean what if it was black panther oh
has it there well
throughout history right yes
uh it could have been like a female
black panther because it did look like a
feminine style oh you're saying the
statue
but that could be related to the missing
chair right also what if what if the
chair is like the tomb of the unknown
soldier and it's always empty or it's
supposed to represent like the people
the people are on the illuminati yes of
course the people that we take good care
of and shouldn't ask any questions
what if it's also there's a level above
the illuminati and that's with the empty
chair
the illuminati yes
[Applause]
that was great speaking of uh
speaking of multiverse of madness quick
plug here for the very cool latest
obsession shirt
uh riffing on the multiverse of madness
this is called shattered madness this is
available at newrockstarsmerch.com
um a couple of us are wearing some new
rockstars merch tommy's got a great uh
no way home meme uh
jessica's got an awesome uh spider-man
or no uh venom uh carnage give him that
hand uh
no yeah the other one yeah
that's spiderman i mean i thought she
was gonna do a fun handshake with you oh
wow i deserved it i deserved it i
blanked i was still thinking spiderman
meme as i looked at benjamin carthage uh
find these shirts that great shirt and
lots of other cool gear at
newrockstarsmerch.com and then we'd also
like to thank our good friends at
hellofresh oh yeah for helping us bring
this episode to you today um
you can get yourself some farm fresh
pre-apportioned uh ingredients click the
link in the description of this video or
head to hellofresh.com
newrockstar16
to get a great deal
breakroom16 thank you off-screen john um
uh they're number one meal kit in
america for a reason we are all big fans
of hello fresh yes and actually we have
some footage jessica cooked a hello
freshman yeah you guys can look at my
dirty hands as i cook so i had some
chicken breasts and i saw them peppered
them up look at my dirty table
and then i sliced up some i sliced up
some yams i was making like a spicy yam
chicken dish and it was a helmet
i have my boyfriend who's six foot seven
holding it and
there it is
like baby food the yams but i swear on
my life you guys it was the
like nicest food i've ever had it was so
good and it i i am not a person that
puts maple syrup in everything but they
made me believe you can put maple syrup
with chili flakes and like some kind of
powder spicy sweet
so good
green beans also kudos jessica on your
uh fun uh different colored bowls yeah
i don't want to spoil too much but we're
going to show my meal later this week
and it will not have the same aesthetics
as this it was a bit of a child's
nightmare but it tasted
delish
speaking of deliciousness you know what
you can get hello fresh meals they end
up it comes out cheaper because they
only send you kind of what you need
cheaper than restaurant food 72 percent
cheaper than restaurant food and you can
use that money you save to buy fancy
mugs look at brandon's uh pirates of the
caribbean limited dish uh the real ones
now but we're not talking about disney
we're talking about hellofresh so eat
along with us this week uh you're gonna
see different footage from different
hosts every day this week as we all
enjoyed hello fresh and head to
hellofresh.com
breakroom16
is the correct url to use and use the
code breakroom16 for up to 16 free meals
yeah 16 free meals that's a lot and
obviously after yesterday's hamstring
fiasco i gotta switch up my diet a bit
my mom actually called me and said i
think you should do hello
in a very gentle mom way and i was like
first of all don't ever tell me what to
do i can't help but notice really quick
everybody in the chat uh i ted is right
it's my imaginary boyfriend it's not
real uh sorry to disappoint so many
people
all of us have both imaginary animals
everybody we're all uh depending on what
we need for them i should say tommy we
did get a super chat from travis who did
say it's time for mandatory fun
travis
really good idea but it's not time yet
now it's time for me to just play my
graphics they just played the graphic
this is my special world where i feel
safe let's have some mandatory fun
yesterday we were a little bit silly a
bunch of silly gooses
creating our fantasy illuminati brandon
had his from the star wars universe
jessica so eloquently introduced uh
animated characters from the fox world
maybe something she's familiar with uh
zach you did movie directors and i of
course brought it home with serial
mascots in a segment that really rocked
the internet
a lot of chatter big bump on all our
socials big big bump uh anyway
awkwardly doctor strange called me last
night
dr stephen strange called me last night
and he said i actually want to hire you
guys to consult on creating a 616
illuminati
a lowly commoner all of us actually he
didn't say you by name he just said does
he know my name he he actually only
named me
uh he said you and those other three i
think he called you guys
goons
so anyway we're going to get to work
here creating a new group of superheroes
all right and so here's what we're gonna
do we're gonna go round by round three
rounds each uh of introducing our our
potential illuminati then each one of us
is going to get a veto off of someone
else's board now potentially
all three of someone's suggestions most
likely mine because i'm a big dumb
animal
will uh will be taken away yeah and then
we will be left with eight
marvel characters of which one will be
killed by scarlet witch and one will be
the empty chair off world person and we
will have our sixth official illuminati
for marvel 616 and then all you break
animals can vote on whether or not you
agree with us
and uh and that's just uh what we call
mandatory [ __ ] and and go ahead and
throw it start throwing in the chat who
you would like to see in the six years
give us some chats
give us some chats you brats all right
now i love bratz i used to collect them
yeah bratz dolls people say i look like
one because i have big eyes and a great
smile
baby
yeah all right anyway uh zach let's just
go in this order all right we're gonna
reveal each of our three picks one at a
time so i wanted to start with uh you
know he's fresh in our minds
and i think he can represent a great
supernatural element that needs to be
represented on the illuminati so i'm
going with my man moon knight
now that counts
because you know what he might have
three also but he's got one butt so he
only wants one chair one one two one
booty three minds
one heart
[Laughter]
all right uh okay so or maybe more mines
uh i went with uh what i think is an
absolute banger of a suggestion
uh rocket raccoon
raccoon
he's really smart he's really agile he's
got a quick wit and he's not afraid to
stand up for what he believes yeah
i like that all right
i went with one of the sexiest men that
i could think of oh okay oh come on jess
i'm not in the him
[Laughter]
here is our big bad boy
i think well is he bad anymore i don't
know
love changed him bold love changes i
went with a classic an original you know
you you can't you can't beat what you
start with let me see we need brains we
need bruce
[Applause]
yeah yeah
yeah that's even more to me
whatever you want they'll shatter that
chair if he hulks out you
my second pick i don't want to tease the
third pick i'm going rhodey okay okay um
as one machine
you know you need somebody to represent
kind of the world military there we saw
in falcon winter soldier he's still in
uniform he's still going around to
ceremonies and handling government
business i think he could he could he
would be a great representative he's a
narc
now i i gotta i gotta preface this i
gotta defend this a little bit
the illuminati is gonna need capital
they're gonna need money okay they're
gonna need someone willing to take risks
and they're gonna need someone a little
desperate for approval from uh powerful
beings that's why my suggestion for
round two is
just
hammer oh my god
i mean he could dance last last scene in
prison that's right last season daddy
owes you one possibly dead i'm gonna
correct your mistake with another hottie
hottie hottie alert staying fresh on the
mind number two is whoa
we need a very powerful person but then
we also need a power person that also
keeps their head yeah he's got to
represent camera taj tommy was right the
alumni is going to need capital okay
they're not taking government funding
yeah all right they need money and they
need a smart tactician someone with a
warrant just be iron man and who who who
beat the avengers who destroyed the
avengers that's right
barrett zemo baby wow
[Applause]
demo
and that nice little suit that suit and
dancing in the club he has a british man
that assassinates people yeah we're
walking around
he's got money never mind
i don't know
there's higher in assassin level wealth
and then there's like helicarrier wealth
i'm just saying i don't know that he's
at the helicopter right all right but
that's a lot of champagne on that jacket
uh share your tax returns at coward
until he releases his tax documents i'll
tell you right now i don't make it they
don't they don't do taxes yeah he
probably doesn't he probably doesn't pay
taxes all right
all right all right he's in the landed
gentry my final pick i'm going with
valkyrie okay
all these people
we know she's the only one who's
currently running a geographic regional
technically do that okay technically
yeah wong is probably running camera taj
but so she's running new asgard right
now we know she's going to be a factor
in thor 11th under and then probably
going forward she makes a lot of sense
she can also represent old asgard which
isn't really a thing but then he has
guardians you know from that plane
anyone floating around in space who can
make it to earth yes you're welcome yes
uh my number three is simple are you all
familiar with the logic uh question of
the ship of thesis all right well what
vision is
what vision is so he can explain it he
can walk through walls tomatoes emotions
[Music]
he can make decisions just entirely on
practicality
that might be the pick that has the
fewest lines of dialogue so far in the
mcu right right oh my god my third is
another hottie
no i went based off skill hotness second
because that's how it goes in the world
sherry princess sherry
we need we need brains we need strength
and brains and we need a superpower
right yeah i think that's what you said
no so no mandates for the illuminati no
vaccine mandates okay
that's real we're not talking actors
okay
sorry my third pick is so obvious i'm
surprised no one has made it yet i mean
how do you not put nick fury
he has to be there hey he's been saving
the world for generations
so now we transition to the veto uh each
of us gets one veto we get to eliminate
one person from contention don't just
make it petty don't just eliminate ones
just because you want to embarrass
someone don't
veto the actor
in the character
i'm fine she's fine she's coming around
uh i'm gonna lead with
maybe i'm not gonna pick off one of
tommy's even though you could justify
picking off anyone else i'm gonna pick
off i want
we were trying to make alliances before
this and now i understand because
okay
look he's dancing like him never mind no
oh a sexy man
um yeah okay that's great less filling
oh yeah i'll veto next i will eliminate
my voice cause yours are all gone
i will
eliminate roadie oh yeah
out of here that's who i was gonna be
rodeoing
had jessica with a strong lead on her
illuminati pics yeah she's leaving the
chat i am absolutely taking your fly
away my princess
[Applause]
out of here
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i'm gonna have to take out justin boy
i mean we gotta get white vision
actually yes thank you thank you
get him out of here
i mean if that's the rule then the
illuminati
okay so now we are we have it down to
eight candidates yes out of these eight
we have to immediately kill one yes one
kills one we have to reach a consensus
on that i think honestly i'm gonna be
straight up i think we should kill
rocket because he's just gonna steal
things and scatter and he hasn't shown a
lot of now he's shown bravery and and
honesty and good friendship kidding not
a lot of leaders in the world not a lot
of leadership not a lot of leadership
not a lot he took control when when they
were split up and guarding the galaxy
yeah what does that do you control the
situation six chefs [ __ ] no you need
someone
rocket would be my last one
i would argue though that like
i mean he has proven himself to be a
more trustworthy figure than loki yeah
i love saying change i will say that
moon knight is a real wild card fury
straight up lies to people
i don't think any of your board should
be taken away it makes complete sense
another 838 okay 616 is different 616 is
for the people 616 is for the children
okay and quite frankly if i'm elected
i will put a chicken in every pot
someone said
damn no love for talking
he's never any love for tonight i think
we'll let tommy keep his rocket i don't
think we can i think
we got to think like wanda here who's
wanda gonna kill one is killing her i
think she's gonna kill loki like yeah
she already tried to kill yeah those are
arguably the most powerful characters
still left on board only keeping the
rocket is because
that's right
[Music]
no he already killed them
bruce banner nick fury that's a strong
one that's not strong
representation and a lot of different
demographics yeah a lot of different uh
different parts of the mcu a lot of
different levels of power eco samurai
and chat is hashtag 616 for the people
and he's right that's right for the
people and just like prom night i'm like
alone we're gonna sneak them back on a
little bit oh come on jess no cheating
we've got some some good uh uh things
coming up in the chat aya zupi uh saying
the portal that mr fantastic arrives in
looks similar to what kang uses for the
tva square block shape right uh same
texture portal a different color yeah
it's a little bluish right well we have
to i mean what we know of the tva just
from 616 right is that it was all like
kang creation this wasn't like a real
thing it was all made by he who remains
to keep that universe in check to keep
him safe to keep them separated from the
rest of the multiverse do we think there
are other tvas out there yeah presumably
right presumably every multiverse has
maybe their own tv well maybe i i don't
know if like they're definitely without
one
specific kang variant right wanted to
create a world where he would be
unkillable until he was until they
figured it out so i don't know that
every kang has that fear that's what i
mean like if 838 is able to if they're
able to look at other multiverses that
means there's no tva stopping them from
doing that yes right so i think ours was
the i think 616 was the only one with a
functioning tva
that works the way we saw it interesting
so to uh circle back to iu zoopy's um
comment maybe it's just you know uh
technology can develop independently but
similarly right right like when the uh
when the end the
combustion engine was being developed
right simultaneously in in both in
germany and in the u.s right a lot of
the developments i mean very similar
right the the film camera was the same
way the uh i think like the telegraph
and the telegram or like that kind of
technology was being developed and i'm
pretty sure the flashlight was
simultaneously created
did we already answer xavier's question
what was your favorite illuminati
that's my favorite question thank you
thank you that is my favorite question
because
i think uh honestly black bolt's death
was so good great for like horror it was
so great to be like where's your mouth
what that just like blood coming it's
something i mean it's something we joke
about often on shows like big question
but like yeah what's the perfect way to
kill a superhero using their powers
against them right so good yeah i mean
xavier said he liked the string cheese
right i did like that too especially
with the pop of the brain at the end
like that was the best part it felt like
they took a note from invincible and uh
if you guys watched invincible but um
invisible at amazon prime when he is
literally murdering all the other
superheroes in the worst way possible i
was like oh they definitely looked like
invincible and was like how can we also
make something traumatic yes and no no
spoiler warning on that because you know
what that show's been out over a year
yeah i know and that happens i think in
the first very sorry like 10 minutes uh
don't even come at us with any kind of
spoiler talk um yeah i i agree that
sequence now i think it's like it leaves
you a little bit cold because you're
like oh i want these characters to stick
around but man what a cool one yeah
showing them getting knocked out it was
perfect and then that poor wanda when
she came to was just like my boys
my boys i'm like you just exploded a
man's head twice yes
uh john ayton uh saying could he open
chair it belonged to namor um yeah
absolutely 100
would love it yeah why didn't they call
him in why didn't he's attending
like get the page and be like i'm not
going to be making out with a swordfish
or something yeah he's fighting black
panther dude you're back to its
swordfish
oh yeah i got time
[Applause]
so of all the fish to make out with
swordfish has to be one of the worst
yeah but that's what makes it so
delightful
that's the comedy top five fish to make
out all right guys mandatory front is
back play by graphics
all right we're talking dishing on
fishing
who's your biggest uh aquatic crush i
call salmon
there were some good uh 616 illuminati
picks from the chat we saw doctor doom
who doesn't exist yet of the six woods
you can have him all right
deadpool i mean that's a pretty
interesting picture i don't know he's
very selfish uh hank pam which i did
consider
as one of mine
for the illuminati i think would be on
it but also think pim would pull a
freaking amore and be like i'm not
showing up yeah he wouldn't he wouldn't
come to every meeting i don't care
because it doesn't necessarily work well
with others she'd be like
bumper nickel bagel i'm leaving honestly
that would be their thing is like we
keep asking him to join and he does not
return well between hank pym and then
the other suggestion cap which i'm going
to assume is old man cap yeah this would
be a very american thing if we had a
couple 90 year old white men they would
they would need a ramp in this
illuminati for sure
and then of course howard
how would the duck should be on the
alumni yeah hell yeah what are they
going to bring howard the duck is
martini do we have any any note of when
we could see him showing up guardians
and what if he was like really in it but
like when am i going to see the when am
i going to see this real cgi
i mean i want to see the variant that
exists from the 1986 film show right i
want to see that that freakish nightmare
of a character show up in the uh
and he should be with leah thompson
again yeah yeah bring leah thompson back
yeah um
right now we're going to get into our
discussion topic because we're getting a
lot of questions about wanda a lot of
questions but the one top question is
wanda dead keeps coming up and whitney
van laningham um my number one uh i
can't say the b word uh number one
number one not there yet number one
forty nine dollars uh is gonna be
breaking down the video about whether or
not wanda is dead tomorrow yeah and guys
by the way if there was ever a reason to
donate 51 to the show so that we can
finally on the air call whitney the
b-word
oh i say it in a great way
beautiful that's my best friend
obviously she's a real bad girl
beautiful daddy got her own money winnie
come over here forcing whitney out of
her office but
whitney get over here talk about your
video that you're doing tomorrow
get her in here yeah
[Applause]
whitney did you already do your video
dude i'm like about to go tape it right
now all right
right now when you guys are done yeah so
we need to wrap this up she's screaming
in that room while you guys are
screaming in this room and it might
explode the building yeah yeah the
multiverse will collapse on it yeah if
you're if you're driving down san
fernando boulevard right now keep the
honking to a minimum keep it honking to
a minimum yeah if you're yeah if you're
driving to where we have our office and
fly it down
like a running gag of giving off our
address we're gonna find us eventually
fill our address we are at one two nope
[Applause]
she lives outside the law that's right
uh
keep an eye out for whitney's video
tomorrow one in the chat said get back
to the blue dungeon
i know yeah that's why you know md eric
and whitney
who occasionally show up on this show
but most of the time they got full-time
gigs they got to be uh
uh sweating and and scraping to get all
those great uh blue screen videos well
yeah i do that yeah
i'll be here every single day until
you know the charges
[Laughter]
i don't think anyone is ever dead in the
mcu until i see their weird funeral with
a bunch of characters and a one
character that we saw in one movie let's
not say like dead for dead but like in
that moment did the corporeal body of
the max stuff of the city absolutely not
that the temple falls down the rings
absolutely not she's just playing dead
she's going to actually walk away
how is that a bunch of blocks gonna
destroy this woman no she never her real
intent there could have been she wants
to destroy the temple because the spells
are written on the wall yeah she's not
actually trying to kill herself no we
saw a red poof a red cosmic like poof of
energy now there could could that have
just been a toot i mean i think they
could have just been destroying the
walls of wondergore i think that giant
fart or after you know basically
a month
of half absorbing america chavez's
powers was that red poof her final
ability to be able to get herself into
another universe like was she like all
right i'm out
like i'm i'm portaling out like i have
somehow obtained this ability the only
thing and this is i was thinking the
same thing but the only thing i would
hate with both of our theories is the
fact of we'd be getting a reverse of
what already happened
oh we got producer john swinging in i
want to i want to throw some fuel on the
fire here i want to finish my point
after you go away oh the only thing that
i would be irritated about is that
what's what we're already getting in
this movie yeah is that she ran to this
like she's like i'm in this own place
getting apples from my apple tree and
then we redo that again
i will say when when uh zombies when
strange finishes his dream walk and
comes back to the uh universe with the
incursion rachel mcadams and him or
christine and him are talking and he
tells her you know america is on her way
and then she says and wanda and he says
no
implying that like
she died right
she's just not well christine is like
checking in on wanda is she is she i
mean that was the implication that i
took is is wanda still a threat alive
whenever he says no i don't think he
knows i'll also assume he knows i don't
think he knows i also think what if
she's just in hell
what if she is just like with mephisto
right now sorry
that scene with the the demons coming in
the eyes i was like oh my god here comes
mephisto yeah but i think like she's
going to win all chatsworth with those
eyes
don't don't look at him oh my also
someone someone just said white vision
will be 616 doctor doom one day
it's right there it starts on the r ra
oh ran to mor elmore yeah it's amore
love that i would love more i would love
that
i was gonna say one last thing one other
thing on on wanda now the final image we
saw of her in one division astral
projecting herself
to be reading the dark hold while she
was her physical corporeal form was
outside sipping tea what if she did a
little bit of that what if that was her
astral projection version that got
squished by the temple while her
physical body is just strolling down
[ __ ] great idea
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
shout out to micah saldivar
send us another chat if you want to hear
a different swear word no i'll text it
to you or i'll tweet it to you um well
you know uh john bringing up like what
was said between uh uh stranger
christina i wanted to one thing i also
noticed on my second viewing of the film
was all right when they're in the
sequence in the temple and uh america
makes the star portal to commentage to
get away with with wong and they go
through the next time we see her open a
portal again uh uh they're coming to get
i think i believe it's to get strange
and christine like they're coming from
the wonder gore mountain area they're
not at commercial so i think after they
go to college they go back to wonder
kind of just to make sure yeah to make
sure everything's get you to moochie
yeah
question for you question for you
because you're bringing this up so they
said they can't use their magic at
wondergore right yeah they're not able
to they can use their magic because he's
using his magic thing to stab that guy
they can't use their magic to sling ring
up to there to get it away which again
is a whole other messed up thing like
why
i think it's more i think it's more so
they're like we abide by the
rules that have been stated for
centuries that we shouldn't use magic at
wonderguard and that's but he obviously
didn't abide by that when he did his
like wonderful maybe that's an enchanted
object versus like your actual magic
maybe so they had to like walk up the
entire mountain to go back in because i
do think they did check it's not
falling maybe they checked from a
distance like
yeah she's good she's good are these
giant creatures
yeah
i i i you know i i really liked how sam
raimi in this movie did a good job of
like reminding the audience what wand
has been through you know the sequence
in her mind which is so cool that white
space with the red smoke it's very
creepy uh you know we see the the real
838 wanda's mind like stuck in the
rubble a great reminder of like what
wanda went through uh and you know the
kind of
poetic end to her is being crushed by
rubble which i think is like kind of
beautiful and strange
and i think like whether we see
elizabeth wilson portray wanda maximov
again which we probably will let's be
honest yeah this is she's dead in the
sense of like this feels like the end of
an arc yeah right maybe the next time
you see her it's a little bit of a soft
reboot even if it's the same actress
playing the same character yeah she's
like oh i'm me from a different
multiverse or i'm i
i got resurrected through some magical
process or whatever but i'm i'm starting
with a fresh slate which is a very
comics thing to do yeah a lot of
characters go through crazy arcs and
turn evil and die and get brought back
as like a nice version of themselves or
whatever and i like the idea of you know
wanda reconstructing vision and this hex
and this kind of nightmare scenario
where at first vision doesn't like it
and then like comes around to it if
white vision has kind of the same
journey where he becomes obsessed with
wanda he's like this is what's missing
from me as a he's like what am i missing
he works
with magic to get back
frankenstein
and she's brought back and she's like i
don't like this like
a super chat from mark this is jessica
snort yesterday deserves a donation yes
my boy mark and always supporting
cameras uh that's
i'm thanking tommy for getting a charlie
horse
by the way feeling good guys we're
almost done with the show and my tendons
are limber they're doing great about
doing some jokes they hydrated out there
first yeah we all lost to the end we got
a couple more super chats we should
address uh franco asked if you see your
variants when you dream does that mean
if you are a lucid dreamer is that
dreamwalking yeah is that dreamwalking
what is the first comic book series
drawn by george perez that you read uh
rest in peace george uh i i always think
lucid dreaming is a scam i don't i don't
i think anyone who says they can do is
just lying yeah he's trying to be cool
no i haven't
you're done lucid dreaming i feel like i
was practicing i was also probably just
you know i was rambunctious in my youth
probably just high or drunk but
and trying to go to sleep
that's everyone's life
that's how you lucid dream is just
getting higher drunk i'm lucid dreaming
right now
no i every now i think i'm having a lot
of dreams recently because i keep
thinking of that line in the movie of
like whenever you dream it's your old
day and i was like okay and i had a
dream last night i had like five kids
and i was like there's a universe where
i have five kids and i was about to pull
a wanda i was about to pull awanda cause
i love babies if it is true for me then
in a lot of multiverses i am late for an
exam
i do not know where my class is held and
there's a lot of various high school and
panic college uh
i just came from a universe where
jessica and i had five kids oh my god
and each one was cuter than the last and
we let them know that one was underrated
kitchen asks hot take we love a hot take
uh could 838 be the cartoon universe
which i do like because you have
professor x in the cartoon outfit oh
it's just like a live action party
like the way we said it that's the same
it's live action but they're really the
cartoons oh that's nice oh that's sick
i uh here for the cookies love that name
yeah uh ass i need a what if spin-off of
darcy and the duck they're going they
have or well they're not going i feel
like they i don't think they actually
will but i would love that i would love
them to just make shorts that were very
popular from what if episodes and that
be one of the shorts what um what what
kind of cookies
are you there for i mean what kind of
cookies apparently what they're here for
the cookies the wookie cookies are dog
treats don't leave off that w
um uh great well uh oh and there's
somebody else that had uh super chatted
in there elizabeth olsen deserves an
oscar for best supporting actress you
know what give her the appointment
i can't endorse her
having a nomination before mary kate and
ashley you have to respect a family with
a legacy okay
it's got to be them first playing the
same role didn't we talk about tanner oh
sorry in a gritty reboot yeah chris just
said something uh didn't we talk about
this yesterday question doesn't no way
home cause an incursion no and i will go
for this again go again go ahead no way
help does not cause an incursion because
it wasn't encouraging you have to deal
with dark magic and they didn't do it
with dark magic the the way home
happened through eldritch magic
right didn't cause
oh wait no sorry uh andy
says outcome of the ultron project was
successful that thanos was even a threat
wasn't that the reason that he was
created so that he couldn't attack
well i yeah i mean if we go by the logic
of the mcu right tony wanted to make
this he's saying the 838 universe yeah
yeah because the ultron centuries are
still around
so does that mean that they were used to
protect the planet earth from thanos
well maybe they were a big part of
protecting it i mean
tony's making the ultrons because he
knows there's aliens out there and they
have superior technology and they can
show up any time he doesn't really know
about thanos so much
uh when when age of ultron it kind of
does because thanos didn't send the
chateau he doesn't know that thanos had
the atari they don't know that like the
tesseract has the space stone and the
staff
uh has the mind stone yet like they're
they're still figuring all that out so
you know i don't think he knew about
thanos and as we saw the ultron bots
they don't know they weren't that crazy
they also were
they the we're assuming we're assuming
i'm not assuming that iron man created
them because what if iron man's not in
this but hank pym would be so hanging
him could have created this yeah so
they're like
richards easily could have done it
um damn it okay uh and you know what on
that note uh i think this concludes this
episode of the break room thank you all
so much for joining us this is our new
rockers
we've got a big um week planned out
please join us for the next three days
of this week at roughly 3 p.m weird i
meant to tell you guys i was here by
myself last night and uh
i came into my office
and someone had moved all of my funko
pops into
uh alphabetical order which makes no
sense because they're numbered phone
calls are numbered you you you might
know there's just been some weird noises
going on around there is it spooky
before friday tommy
this i bet i bet this is unrelated to
the fact that we'll be celebrating our
friday the 13th
uh show on friday i'm our first ever i'm
so glad i won again i'm sure that is
completely unrelated to what tommy was
just talking about so please join us
we'll be horror
yet up uh we'll be uh getting a bunch of
little [ __ ] oh
you're nasty little horrors
uh yeah we'll get we'll get an
illuminati on friday yeah ooh
miss jackson so please join us also join
us uh wednesday and thursday too and we
thank you for your support we thank you
for all the super chatters for uh
throwing that in there and all the
people participating in the chat that
have been supporting this show this show
has been a bigger success than we
anticipated already excited to do it and
we're gonna keep working on it making it
better and trying to attract new folks
that will enjoy it so thank you all for
being here thank you guys and as always
we thank jerry hughes for 11 years on
the buffalo game all right we'll see you
guys tomorrow
[Applause]
[Music]